but I get it so long now what you think
about oh I miss her so much I miss her
so much
what they talk about and what they do
when we are not home that ball of fluffs
got a screw loose going to be your
brother boy I got a bad situation I'm
your friend and as your friend I got to
be honest with you I don't care about
you or your problems this is my
apartment now
and my new bear oh dude Katie's gonna be
so upset when she sees that he's gonna
flip out it's just one vase is it Duke
is it oh that's a shame he's gonna be
gone soon Hey
so long oh my gosh what happened to you
oh just ignore what just happened okay
I'll find your friend
how you been all time paralyzed great
you're climbing like an animal right
no wait but I still look good I look
good discover the secret life of pets
you're a good boy Leonard
still on Mill
bye Gidget hey max hey gadget any plans
today yes big big stuff today Gidget I
got big plans I'm gonna sit here and I'm
gonna wait for Katie to come back oh
that sounds exciting
well I won't interrupt I've got a very
busy day - here you go
see you later Chloe Shillong Mel bye
sweet pea
see you Gino
you be a good boy Leonard
bye sweetie
I'm Max and I'm the luckiest dog in New
York because of her so long now
guys today I got big plans I'm gonna sit
here and I'm gonna wait for Katie to
come back oh I miss her so much
I have some big news
this is Dooku I'm going to be your
brother Chloe Chloe I got a bad
situation Katie brought home a
psychopath from the pound I don't even
have a bed now I'm sleeping on the floor
like a dog Lucas is ruining our lives
he's rude it's an emergency
you know cutie pie your own business oh
my gosh what happened to you
we've got JD's gonna be worried sick we
had a great thing going I blame myself
yeah me too
I blame you a lot what busted both of
you out of here but from now on you work
for me it's me oh just ignore what just
happened
okay that's my city I'll find you a
friend we gotta take this super drug
okay the secret route was dead we can
find our way home we are descended from
the mighty wolf
we have raw primal instincts hi how are
you there are moments away from leading
us home this is home that way
seriously the secret life of this be a
good boy Leonard
see you later Chloe
whoa
whoo let's go first oh just ignore what
just happened ok heyno hey gadget any
plans today yes big big stuff today
Gidget I got big plans I'm gonna sit
here and I'm gonna wait for Katie to
come back well I won't interrupt I've
got a very busy day to give you a good
boy Leonard
oh this is not an Easter Bunny this is
not an Easter bonnet these are not
Easter eggs oh just ignore what just
happened okay
Happy Easter from the Secret Life of
that's rated PG I'm max but I'm the
luckiest dog in New York because of her
stop guys I got big plans I'm gonna sit
here and I'm gonna wait for Katie to
come back oh I miss her so much I have
some big news this is Dooku I'm going to
be your brother Chloe Chloe I got a bad
situation Katie brought home a
psychopath from the pound I don't even
have a bed now I'm sleeping on the floor
like a dog Duke is this ruining our
lives
you know cutie pie oh my gosh what
happened to you JD's gonna be worried
sick we had a great thing going I blame
myself yeah me too I blame you a lot
what Buster both of you out of here but
from that one you work for me advantage
me oh just ignore what just happened
okay this is my city
Oh fine your friend we gotta take this
super grep okay the secret route was dad
we can find our way home we are
descended from the mighty wolf we have
raw primal instincts hi how are you
there are moments away from leading us
home is it home that way seriously the
secret life of pets
be a good boy Leonard
love you Maxie wonder what the pets we
love do when we move from the humans
behind Despicable Me hi how are you the
secret life of pets you be a good boy
Leonard
Oh
stop guys any plans today I got big
plans